[Music]
the product of millions of years of
evolution the human body is capable of
many remarkable things but none of which
may be quite so incredible as the
development of life in utero over 3
million babies are born each year in the
United States alone worldwide the
highest fertility rate is found in
nature where the average woman gives
birth to approximately 6.49 children in
her lifetime
Singapore sits on the opposite end of
the spectrum at just 0.83 less than one
earth per woman while the number of
births customs and traditions vary from
culture to culture the developmental
process is essentially universal derived
from the Latin word pregnant him meaning
before birth pregnancy is the period in
which the fetus develops inside the womb
typically lasting around 40 weeks human
pregnancies are divided into three
trimesters of 3 months each
pregnancy begins in the uterus where a
sperm fertilizes an egg if the sperm
carries an X chromosome the baby will
become female while a Y chromosome will
result in the baby becoming male the
fertilized egg or zygote divides
repeatedly as it travels through the
fallopian tube implanting itself on the
uterine wall to form both the embryo and
a specialized organ known as the
placenta found only a new Syrian or
placental mammals the placenta will
manage waste and provide key nutrients
oxygen and hormones via the umbilical
cord the brain which will continue to
grow and develop throughout the
pregnancy makes up nearly half of the
embryo in these early stages as the eyes
nose ears and mouth along with all major
organs continue to develop in month 3
the baby will begin to look more and
more human with each passing day the
second trimester lasts from weeks 13 to
27 the fetus will more than double in
size during this time and soon it
smoothness may be felt by the mother
hearing first develops around week 18
but the fetus will not respond to sounds
outside of the womb until approximately
week 25 starting at week 28 and lasting
up until delivery the third trimester is
a time for final touches such as
eyelashes and taste buds with most major
development complete the fetus will gain
nearly half a pound a week to make room
for this rapid growth the mother's
internal organs adjust significantly
throughout the pregnancy dropping lower
into the pelvis a fetus typically turns
heads down in preparation for birth most
bones will have hardened by this time
though the skull will remain relatively
soft to ease the delivery process labor
is divided into stages beginning with
the dilation of the cervix and resulting
in the delivery of both the baby and the
placenta
[Music]
despite thousands of years of human
pregnancies scientific understanding has
only recently begun to catch up leading
to an increase in success and safety for
both mother and child as our
understanding of pregnancy continues to
develop
so do technology and reproductive
medicine with much more in store for the
future of pregnancy
[Music]